CAPTAIN, BRADY
TKACHUK.   GIVES IT
AWAY.
TKACHUK, POINT BLANK,
AND AS SAVE BY THING, B
SHOT, THEY'VE GOT TO
RESPOND IN KIND.
>> Jack: BRUINS, ON
THE POWER PLAY, 54 12
IN THE CLOSES.
CHABOT HOLDS HIGH. >> A
DISCIPLINE TRIANGLE
BY BOSTON.
THEY WERE AGGRESSIVE.
CARLO,
McAVOY TOOKOKME THE OTH
NIGHT 1!
SHOT.
I THINK IT IS OFF
NET.
IT DEFINITELY O THE ATT
ZONE.
JAKE DeBRUSK TO
HAULA.
A SAVE BY MURRAY GETS
KNOCKED ON HIS CATT
HAS TWO ICE IT.
>> An
TH BE
COMMUNICATION.
PEOPLE NEED TO
SWITCH.
THEY NEED TO HAVE
SOME KIND OF
COMMUNICATIONBY SWAYMAN
STUTZLE,
>> Andy: NOW, LET' STRU
WITH KEEPING UP TO PLAY
FREDERIC, WITH A NICE
TRIP PASS.
THE BACKHAND BY
CREASE AND SEV
COULD HAVE READ
NICELY AT THAT
CHABOT TO PASTRNAK.   B
WITH CHABOT.
HE TAKES A GREAT T
BERGERON SCORE
PASTRNAK .
AND THEY TOO FAR FORWAR
PAST
GOES DIRECTLY TO THE
BENCHTHE FOUR-LINE, IT
AP
IT LOOKS LIKE McAVOY
WAS GOING TO MAKE A
PLAY ON